foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story tonight Prince Harry's
claims of industrial scale phone hacking
as he finishes two days on the stand
it's a lot he admits as he's questioned
on tabloid's stories about
ex-girlfriends and a visit to a strip
club
it's on me the Prime Minister tells Sky
News he'll take personal responsibility
if he fails to meet his economic ledges
an environmental bomb of mass
destruction we witnessed the evacuation
of communities devastated by the
Ukrainian Dam destruction all these
trees are submerged the houses the whole
of the basement and the first floor has
gone
and you can hear the sound as they're
still trying to defend themselves
painting the city orange how wildfires
in Canada are bringing deadly pollution
to New York
and we'll take a look at tomorrow's
front pages and I'll press preview
that's starting from 10 30 this evening
[Music]
hi there very good evening to you and we
start with some breaking news tonight
West Ham are just seconds away from
winning the Europa conference League
after we think about to uh beat they
have just beaten the Italian team
Fiorentina playing in Prague tonight
well our correspondent Rob Harry is
joins us now live from Prague at a
historic night to say the least for West
Ham Rob
yeah the chairs just erupting in the
stadium behind me the full-time whistle
is blown and West Ham have won the
Europa conference League beating
Fiorentina 2-1 it was heading to extra
time but then Jared Bowen scored in a
90th minute to seal that 2-1 win and
clinching West Ham's first European
title since 1965 the first trophy of any
sort since 1980 in the FA Cup a huge
night of celebrations West Ham fans
absolutely Delirious the dream has come
true a season when they were fighting
relegation at one point there were
questions over the future of the manager
David Moyes but he's LED this run all
the way through to the Europa conference
League final unbeaten and winning here
in Prague there was a slight staying on
the night in the first half when West
Ham fans did through objects at
fiorentina's Captain it was a warning in
the stadium for them to stop stop they
did their behavior was then impeccable
for the rest of the game and now they
have a wondrous night to celebrate in
East London they are absolutely a
erupting there and I'm sure the partying
will go into the night here in Prague
too
he won't believe it there for now thank
you
very much
let's get back to our top story tonight
it's a lot and a mission from Prince
Harry about the strain of two days of
intense cross-examination at his hacking
trial as he said he would be
disappointed if the court didn't find in
his favor today's question topics
included a prank voicemail left by his
brother William A Visit to a strip club
and the breakup with his former
girlfriend Chelsea Davey now there are
no cameras inside the high court but
here on Sky News we're showing you what
Prince Harry had to say voiced by an
actor our home editor Jason Farrell
reports
back for more the hacked off Prince
hoping to expose the tabloids the irony
of a privacy case that all the
embarrassment is relived today questions
about visiting a lap dancing club in his
early 20s cavorting at a rugby match
untrue says Harry and the breakup with
an old flame Chelsea Davey over 15 years
ago
because cameras aren't allowed in court
we've used an actor to portray what was
said hurray Harry's dump was hurtful to
say the least such a private moment was
turned into a bit of a laugh the fact
that payments were referenced to project
Harry is incredibly disturbing yeah it
is it's the level of surveillance I was
under was quite something
Harry is referring to payments to
private investigators he believed were
used to dig up stories using unlawful
methods including phone hacking which he
claims also contributed to this article
about his relationship with TV presenter
Caroline Flack
the story makes it very clear that the
photographers were there before I got
there they saw me arriving on this
evening that was
strictly between myself and Caroline who
is no longer with us and my friend Mark
Dyer
and three of us communicated over the
phone leaving each other voicemails as
to how that poker night was going to
happen
while all the focus is on him he has to
turn the spotlight on the newspapers the
Battleground in this courthouse is 33
articles that Prince Harry says were
obtained using illegal information
gathering the mirror group lawyer has
often been able to demonstrate that
other newspapers are running the stories
or there may have been legitimate ways
of gathering that information and the
question was could Prince Harry
demonstrate that some of that
information was obtained through hacking
or blagging lagging is obtaining
information by deception or
impersonation I think Harry's land is
some punches in relation to the actual
evidence that he'll need to prove his
case
um for example
um some of the investigations that were
conducted by private investigators and
the fact that some of the payments to
those investigators were labeled as for
example Chelsea watch and Harry project
for example the Chelsea watch in
relation to the breakdown of their
relationship that's the kind of evidence
that will be crucial because he needs
that kind of evidence rather than
circumstantial evidence
Harry talked to the tracking device
placed on his ex-girlfriend's car
stalker photographers knowing where he'd
be what he couldn't do under
cross-examination was point to specific
hacked messages that led to stories
appearing in papers but questioned by
his own lawyer he said this
I remember a lot of missed calls that
lasted one second
I remember a lot of people asking me did
you get my voicemail
but I do not remember how consistent it
was
but what I was told about the fact that
this was hacking it all made sense after
giving evidence Prince Harry stayed in
court to watch one of his alleged
tormentors The Mirror's former Royal
correspondent Jane Kerr give evidence
she'd written 10 of the 33 contentious
articles and the court was told she'd
commissioned private investigators 900
times while at the mirror but Jane Kerr
couldn't recall all of her sources for
these stories she claimed some came from
other newspapers such as this drug one
and she denied asking third parties to
do anything unlawful but admitted she
didn't check they weren't this is coming
home to roost at last in the shape of
Prince Harry because here they've
they've they've got an opponent who
really is not worried about winning
money he's worried about winning the
argument
in a day and a half of cross-examination
Prince Harry sometimes floundered but
has also left questions hanging about
how papers got certain bits of private
information about him and for an
organization known to have hacked phones
over that time period why wouldn't they
hack one of their best story makers
Jason Farrell Sky News
hello Royal correspondent Laura bundock
has been reporting from outside the high
court in central London throughout the
day and she joins me now live so Laura
will the prince regard the past two days
as mission accomplished
well that's the big question isn't it
look Harry left with a little smile and
I think a lot of relief it's all over
for him it hasn't been easy for him
being cross-examined I think that final
question from his own embarrassed about
how he was feeling was so revealing that
long pause Harry took answering in a
voice so faint we could barely make out
in court what he had said it's a lot was
his answer because of course it has been
a lot he is taking this huge personal
risk trying to take on the media and
over the last couple of days we've been
given a real sense of the impact all
these articles had on him and a sense of
his conviction that he has a case
because this was all his choice this was
his chance to come to court to try and
prove that mirror group newspapers were
intruding into his private life by
unlawful means and over this long period
of time he wants those responsible held
to account he talked also about how he
wants to stop the hate against Megan but
there is a much bigger purpose there
always has been he's pitched himself as
this Crusader for change when it comes
to the me the media I think the real
issue will be if he wins what does he
end up achieving because whilst he's got
this personal Crusade can he gather and
Garner enough support to try and bring
about a wider reform he'll need public
support he'll need support from
politicians for now he heads back to the
U.S it's all over for him but he simply
has to wait there are three other
claimants in this whole case they'll
have their time in the witness stand as
well and then the judge will go off and
try and come to some sort of decision
and we're told he will take his time
with this ruling and it may be several
months before we find out what his
findings are
okay Laura for now thank you very much
and for more from Laura you can scan the
QR code on screen now for extra analysis
today's events on the latest edition of
The Sky News Daily podcast Kim Leonard
and Laura will take you through
everything that you need to know about
the Duke's second day of evidence you
can subscribe to the Daily for free
wherever you get your podcasts
now Rishi sinek has told Sky News it is
absolutely his responsibility if he
fails to meet his Target to halve
inflation it comes as a new forecast
shows the UK is on track to have one of
the highest inflation rates in the G20
this year the Prime Minister was
speaking disguise political editor Beth
Rigby on his first visit to the U.S
Capitol since he took office in October
and ahead of a meeting tomorrow with
President Biden
back on U.S soil this a prime minister
at home on both sides of the Atlantic in
Washington DC for his fourth meeting
with President Biden in as many months
old allies in times of peace and War the
Prime Minister honoring U.S servicemen
at Arlington National Cemetery two
Nations bow not just by past conflicts
but current ones too prime minister you
say you don't know yet who is
responsible for the dam attack in
Ukraine but if it turns out that Russia
is responsible what actions will you
take it's too early for us to say
definitively the cause of the attack our
military and security services are
currently investigating it but if it is
intentional it would represent an
unprecedented level of barbarism
in lockstep on Ukraine the Prime
Minister wants to use this trip to get
his foot in the door on artificial
intelligence and play a leadership role
in mitigating its risks it's confusing
can you paint a picture of the risk well
look I'm not I'm not going to get into
this business of of scaremongering
people because I think what people will
say well hang on there's a new
technology which we don't fully know yet
what it's capable of doing the pace of
that technology is accelerating at a
rate that people didn't quite think was
possible so what you're saying is if
it's not regulated properly it could be
on the scale of equivalent to nuclear
risk it could kill humans we have to
monitor it I have to regulate it it's
absolutely right that we put guard rails
in place because the technology is
enormously powerful it's going to
reshape every aspect of our lives and
whilst that will bring many
opportunities and benefits it also poses
risks not just existential but also
risks of misuse of the technology
the PM looking for a win on AI here but
back home at risk of missing his own
Target to Harbor inflation by December
with all the Fallout that brings two of
your five pledges a con inflation half
by the end of the year the UK out of
recession by the end of the year if you
fail on either of them do you take
personal responsibility you don't blame
the bank of England you don't blame
consumers you don't blame businesses
it's on you parsley because they're your
personal Prejudice of course it's on me
personally I'm the Prime Minister I'm
the person who set out those five
pledges to halve inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
to stop the boats and I intend to
deliver on those so it's a deal break
with the British public if you don't
deliver it by the end of the year that's
on you it's absolutely my responsibility
I've told the public to hold me
accountable they should be able to have
politicians who deliver what they say
and that's what I intend to do
pm to meetings on Capitol Hill how do we
make all of that relation strong to deal
with the challenges
here to discuss the special relationship
with key leaders across the political
divide tomorrow to the Oval Office for a
one-on-one with President Biden where
he'll hope to turn warm words into
concrete winds bath Rigby Sky News in
Washington
well Beth joins are now live from
Washington this evening and Beth as you
were saying today was the Preamble
tomorrow the main event with the
president what do you think the PM hopes
to achieve
well I think the first thing to say is
that there is definitely a warming of
the relationship between the US and UK
with these two actors in respective
offices I think uh Rishi sunak is helped
by the fact that he is a different type
of prime minister to both Boris Johnson
and Liz truss and also the fact that he
resolved those post-brexit deal trade in
wars and Rouse with the EU both big
ticks are in the Biden camp but what
about the action I think on AI this is a
prime minister that's largely been cut
out of the regulatory discussions
because we're not in the EU and this has
really gone on between the US EU and
then also China so he really wants to
insert himself into that discussion
there's a couple of things to look out
for can he secure fastly in AI Summit
later this year in London or the UK to
talk about the prospect of Regulation he
would see that as a win he also wants to
try and put it into Biden mind that it
might be that the UK might be a good
location to whole host that
International regulator can you get
Biden to bite on that idea so that's AI
I think on trade look the conservatives
promised that we would have a fee free
trade agreement with the US by the end
of 2022 that is now on Ice it's not even
being discussed but there are areas on
trade that he will want to try and
Tackle with President Biden not least
the issues around the inflation
reduction act this is a 370 billion
dollar package by the us to have green
subsidies to try and boost Green
Technology domestically but it's thrown
up some trade barriers for other
countries badenok are a trade secretary
calling it protectionists so can the
Prime Minister get some wins for
exporters British exporters of green
technologies exporting to the US so I
think that for all the warm words
there's a few concrete things we're
looking for to see if Mr sunac can turn
this special relationship into some
special deals for him
okay Beth live in Washington thank you
Aquarius President Vladimir zielinski
says that hundreds of thousands of
people have been left without normal
access to drinking water after the
breaching of the kakovka dam residents
in southern Ukraine are bracing
themselves for water levels to rise even
higher after the dam collapsed the
streets of Curzon have been devastated
with some residents forced to spend the
night on the roofs of their homes our
special correspondent Alex Crawford has
been witnessing the rescue operation
there and sent us this report
old and frail and terribly scared are
still being brought to Safety in their
thousands
[Music]
there's a grateful kiss for her Rescuers
many of these elderly folk lived alone
with their pets
others were confined to their
Wheelchairs and unable to leave
themselves
it's okay it's okay they reassure
yevgenia as she clings to them she's
partially blind and clearly confused and
terrified
senior U.N officials say this
humanitarian crisis will have grave and
far-reaching consequences
many of these people left with barely
any of their possessions
their homes are destroyed and now
there's little safe drinking water
among those who managed to make it to
kherson City a group who fled from the
russian-controlled area
Katarina is amongst them and in her 84
years she's not experienced anything
like this barbarity
they were surrounded by Russian troops
and tellers of beaches being bombed as
they tried to flee to Ukrainian
territory and how the Russian soldiers
tried to steal their boats
all our boats had been sunk she told us
and they were looting our summer houses
and our boat engines they were taking
everything
a huge area of the battlefield is now
submerged with levels Rising 11 feet in
just 24 hours and no sign of it receding
just yet the Ukrainian president has
spoken of enough fresh water now being a
real concern all these trees are
submerged the houses the whole of the
basement and the first floor has gone
and you can hear the sound as they're
still trying to defend themselves
amphibious vehicles like the sherp with
its specialized inflatable tires are
being used to get through these Waters
and there are scores of volunteers
working alongside soldiers and police
trying to pull to safety as many people
as possible
turn around Mercola tells him it'll be
easier
there are at least four people left in
this block with those in the lower
levels moving in with Neighbors in the
flats above were you scared being
stranded there overnight
yes it was scary your tells us I was
afraid water just came in and you
couldn't do anything
there are a lot of animals still being
found to many of the rescued humans they
have been their Lifeline in this
protracted War
the Russians are still insisting they're
not responsible for this catastrophic
disaster as The ukrainians Scrambled to
save as many creatures however tiny as
possible
there are dire predictions of just how
badly this will hit the country long
term not just household pets but their
livestock their Farm exports
agricultural stocks will all be badly
impacted too and the consequences of the
dam burst is likely to be felt for years
to come Alex Crawford Sky News in
southern Ukraine
yeah
well president zielinski has called the
failure of the dam which he blames on
the Russians an environmental bomb of
mass destruction our energy and climate
change correspondent Han Thomas Peter
has been looking at the impact of what's
been called an ecological catastrophe
the destruction of the Nova karkov down
will have profound and far-reaching
consequences for Ukraine from the
immediate crisis to the long term the
biggest emergency right now of course is
the flooding caused by one of the
country's largest reservoirs draining
away to the South dozens of towns and
Villages lying along the low banks of
the depot River have flooded or are
expected to be flooded and around 40 000
already vulnerable people are thought to
be in danger this is a satellite picture
of Southeast Hassan from just last month
and now look you can see how devastating
the flooding has been but the fact that
this area is also a conflict Zone makes
it even more dangerous another concern
which we have is the mobilization of
land mines and exploded Ordnance so the
sniper Riverbanks have essentially been
the front line for months and we know
that mines will have been in place by
Russian forces potentially Ukrainian
forces and flood waters have the ability
to strip away soil and sand and
move that Minds which are underneath
but the emptying of the reservoir is
causing problems beyond the flooding
Ukraine's President Vladimir zelenski
has warned that hundreds of thousands of
people in the region have been left
without proper access to drinking water
and agriculture officials have said that
tens of thousands of Acres of fertile
Farmland that once relied on the
reservoir for irrigation are now at risk
of becoming deserts in the next year
this would have a massive impact on
Global Food Systems Ukraine for example
supplies 35 of the world's sunflower oil
and in addition to all of this there are
now real concerns about long-term damage
to the Region's wildlife and nature
Reserves
as a result of the destruction of the
Kahoka hydroelectric power station at
least 150 tons of machine oil have
leaked into the river with the risks of
an additional 300 tons seeping out
this video shows a large number of dead
fish on the banks of the reservoir as
the water levels drop just at the end of
spawning season
it is too early in this unfolding story
to understand the full extent of the
disaster but it's now clear that
whatever happens Ukraine will be
counting the cost of this for many years
to come
Hannah Thomas Peter reporting there and
let's return to that breaking news now
for you West Ham have won the Europa
conference League final beating
Fiorentina to win their first trophy in
43 years well Rob Harris rejoins Us
Again live from Prague this evening hi
there to you rob a historic evening to
say the least for West Ham and indeed
the fans tell us how the game played out
well it was a game a few chances in the
first half not a classic of a European
final but then it did come to life on
the pitch in the second half and it was
West Ham that got the Breakthrough
thanks to a penalty that was awarded
from a helpful handball awarded by a VR
decision and they had signed Ben Rama
converting from the penalty spot to put
West Ham in the lead absolute delirium
from the West Ham fans but this was a
lead that would only last five minutes
with Fiorentina then equalizing
disappointing those West Ham fans as we
see now Giacomo Brian Ventura going
through on goal to score The Equalizer
and that's led to West Ham Hearts being
broken they thought that it was heading
to extra time but then the ball came
through to Jared Bowen and just in time
slotted into the net to clinch a 2-1
Victory David Moyes absolutely ecstatic
a first major trophy for him a season
when he was fighting relegation ends
with a European title but there was an
ugly moment of the night before the
goals in the first half fiorentina's
Captain was hit with objects thrown from
the West Ham fans and the captain was
led with a blooded head and a cut to it
West Ham have though issued a statement
tonight condemning the incident after
the game in it they do say West Ham
unreservedly condemned the behavior of a
small number of individuals who threw
objects onto the pitch during tonight's
UEFA Europa conference League final the
statement continues these actions have
no place in football and do not in any
way represent the values of our football
club and the overwhelming majority of
our supporters who have behaved
impeccably in Prague this week we will
work with police and other stakeholders
review the incidents and act against
anyone found guilty of an offense well
in the last few moments though it's been
happier scenes on the pitch with West
Ham Captain Declan rice picking up the
Europa conference League trophy it might
well be his last act as West Ham Captain
he's in demand for a big move and you
can see why tonight
deed Rob for now thank you very much
well let's get some reaction for you to
that West Ham win that's closer to home
Skies ritual venables is at a fan Zone
in East London for us and for those not
lucky enough to get a ticket to go to
Prague how they've been reacting Rachel
oh I don't think they need to be in
Prague to feel how special this moment
is the fans have been singing and
screaming and chanting themselves of
course
with me foreign
you can feel the emotion here you can
hear them scream their Delight first
that moment when the penalty was scored
then Devastation with an equalizer a few
moments later and then as we were
minutes into injury time that final win
2-1 to West Ham they've just watched as
their team lift trophies into the air
the first silverware the first Victory
really for West Ham in more than 40
years you can see what it means to them
and I think the partying is going to go
on well into the night here in East
London I'm sure it will for now though
Rachel thanks very much
millions of people across New York City
and northeast America have been told to
avoid going outside unnecessarily as
smoke from wildfires in Canada causes
unhealthy levels of air pollution Canada
is battling hundreds of out of control
fires which have spread from Western
provinces to Quebec evacuations of those
in the fire path are now underway and
lack of visibility due to the Smoke have
caused delays and cancellations at New
York airports our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone reports
an unprecedented weight of smoke hanging
over the Manhattan skyline it is the
consequence of wildfires many hundreds
of miles to the North in Canada
across the city as the hours passed the
spectacle persisted a remarkable
reflection of how weather events impact
well beyond where they hit
on the ground New Yorkers were out but
told not to be the health risks of air
like this are not familiar to people
here but they are of a level regularly
experienced in Indian and Chinese cities
it began on Tuesday this was
mid-afternoon it looked more like dusk
and it is persisting from over the
bridge in New Jersey Manhattan obscured
and look at this the Yankees game with
the smoke above yesterday New Yorkers
sore and smelled something that has
never impacted us on this scale before
even as I was out walking the streets
clearly you knew something was happening
that was beyond normal this is an
unprecedented event in our city and New
Yorkers must take precaution
the advice was predictable not to
exercise outside and to wear a mask the
scientists spelled out why
levels that people if they were to be
outside especially if they're exercising
breathing faster they're going to be
inhaling particulates at concentrations
at normal smokers would inhale
this remarkable satellite image on a
loop over Quebec in Canada shows the
cause clusters of wildfires 500 miles
north of New York
more than 100 fires are said to be out
of control it's worse than normal
because of persistently hot dry weather
an area about the size of Belgium has
already been burnt
at its peak the air quality up in New
York was the worst in the world it has
come down now but the winds have brought
the smoke South and here in Washington
the air is said to be unhealthy and has
been all day
no significant weather changes are
expected anytime soon and we are only at
the start of America's Wildfire season
Mark Stone Sky News in Washington
well that was Sky News at 10 for you
coming up we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's papers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
telegraph tomorrow will come up in just
a few minutes time it's talking about
sunac telling Biden in that all
important meeting tomorrow the UK can
lead on AI now tonight we're going to be
joined by The Economist and broadcaster
Steve Richards and also the Daily Mail
Economist uh Sarah Vine let's see just a
few moments
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching Sky News
it's a moment the oppressed preview of
first look at what's going on the front
pages as they arrive here at the Sky
News Center first though a recap for you
on our top stories tonight Prince Harry
has said it's beyond any doubt that
phone hacking was taking place on an
industrial scale during his final day
giving evidence in course
flood water levels have continued to
rise after the collapse and destruction
of a dam in Ukraine in which some are
calling Europe's worst environmental
disaster since Chernobyl and West Ham
have beaten Fiorentina two on in the
Europa conference League final winning
their first trophy in 43 years
foreign
good evening you're watching the Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive here at the
Sky News Center time to see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
and broadcaster Steve Richards we're
also joined tonight by The Daily Mail
columnist Sarah Vine thank you both for
staying up late and joining us tonight
they're going to be with us from now
until midnight this evening first so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages as they come in tonight starting
with the metro newspaper it splashes
with Prince Harry's claim that he once
found what he believed to be a tracking
device on his ex-girlfriend Chelsea
Davies car
the telegraph tomorrow leads on which is
sunax visit to the United States it says
that he will tell President Biden that
the UK will take the lead in tackling
the threat posed by artificial
intelligence The Daily Mail focuses on
news that as of today 43 police forces
across the country say they've sent
officers to visit a hundred percent of
burgled homes
our press preview colleague Piper
Carrera has a scoop in the guardian
tomorrow reporting the Boris and Kerry
Johnson broke covered restrictions by
hosting a friend at Checkers to help
them plan their wedding on to the eye it
understands that the energy regulator of
gem intends to make suppliers compensate
customers for hidden charges that they
were forced to pay now the ft's UK
Edition is embargoed until midnight we
have the US edition for you though the
version pictures the heavy smog
currently blight in New York City of
course Mark Stone reporting on that few
minutes ago here on Sky News and on to
the star as well for you it tells us we
don't necessarily have to fear from
swimming with sharks
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
that you're going to see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch with us well let's meet our
guests again tonight as I said we're
joined by Steve Richards and Sarah Vine
a very good evening to both of you I
know that you've been looking ahead to
what's happening in the papers and we're
going to start with the front of the
Metro tonight and of course their
coverage if you can imagine it would
always lead with Harriet it's exactly
what they've done
um Sarah take us away with this one
Harry's car tracker bombshell why do you
think they've decided to focus on this
particular line of questioning that
Prince Harry was under in the high court
today
I don't know because most of the
questioning is the problem with Larry is
that a lot of his responses to these
questions have actually been very vague
so in this case he says uh that he found
a tracker on his then girlfriend's car
Chelsea Davey
um and his sort of his explanation for
It is Well it happened to a friend of
mine therefore it must have been a
newspaper who did it that did it but the
problem is he needs to prove these
things you can't
you know you can't just say vaguely as
he has done you know I I'm I I think
this was happening I think this was a
this story was was obtained um through a
hacking an illegal hacking it's got to
be you absolutely got once you get to
court and you get in front of a
barrister you've got to be able to prove
what you're saying and I think the
problem that he's had over the last
couple of days is that he hasn't really
landed a killer blow
um to the mirror uh that you know he's
there's lots of speculation lots of
things that could you know could have
been mistakes could have been done wrong
could have been criminality but nothing
really seems to have come through as
proof and I think that this of the the
Chelsea Davey tracker thing is is a
quite a good example of that because
it's it's yes it it would indicate that
somebody was trying to follow him but
the question is who and I don't think he
really has the answer to that yeah just
reading a bit further into this uh into
the how the uh Metro have covered it
Steve they say that uh that that David
Sherborne of course that is the KC the
the lawyer for
um Prince Harry asked him or how did you
know and he said because we found it as
we as a friend had done to them in
London so that they did find the tracker
But as Sarah says they just don't know
who put it there
yeah and we could analyze the specifics
for the next 24 hours but I think what
is much more interesting is the broader
picture we don't have many troublemakers
in politics at the moment and we need
troublemakers I like troublemakers and
here is a troublemaker in capital
letters uh the royal family rarely speak
in public on anything other than a few
banalities and he has decided to take on
the media which is very Mighty in the
United Kingdom and I think it is
courageous he could have a much easier
life not doing this
um but he is and there's something quite
extraordinary about it it's kind of
Shakespearean on one level this Prince
and Exile coming back to a British Court
to take on the media and to be honest
the specific Sarah might be absolutely
right that nothing is proven but to step
back from that
what uh incredible Dynamic this is of
it's a lot to do with his mother
but most Royals when you think about it
I know they are revered on the whole
don't do things which are surprising and
interesting and whatever you think about
here this is surprising and interesting
and I think impressive
um yeah so what do you I mean do you do
you agree with Stephen is this
courageous of Prince Harry it's
definitely it's become a life mission of
his well I think I think Prince Harry's
psychosis is as as Steve said he's very
damaged by his upbringing and what
happened to his mother
um but a lot of that is to do with his
his family and and the way his uh father
treated his mother and what happened
subsequently
um and Harry's focus is the media he
sees them as the villain of the piece
but it's more complex than that the the
the problem I think a lot of people have
with Harry is that a lot of the people
do feel sorry for him I feel a lot of
sympathy for him for all of those
reasons but he's written this awful book
that he's published in which he is
basically doing to his family what he
accuses the Press of doing to him so you
know in the book he talks about how his
brother isn't as good looking as he used
to be in how his hair's all falling out
and then he talks about his father you
know taking his teddy bear from his
childhood he and he says he he gives
away all sorts of very personal private
things about his family which is
precisely the stuff that he claims has
damaged him so much so I think what
we're dealing with here is somebody who
is in a lot of pain very angry uh wants
to lash out wants to find a solution but
it's you know it's just much more
complex than that and the problem with
putting yourself in the courtroom like
that is that when you make these
accusations in the courtroom you have to
be able to prove them you can't just say
oh well I found a Tracker and because it
happened to amazing mine I assumed that
therefore this was happening to me
that's not good enough in a court of law
and he's put himself in that situation
and I don't think it's particularly good
for him I think whoever's advising him
whoever his friends are
need to try and stop him from doing this
to himself because he is I mean I think
yes it is it is fascinating and it is
interesting and all of those things but
it's not good for him apart from
anything else I mean ultimately you know
he is just ripping off us cat all the
time before before we move on one final
word from Steve on this and do you think
ultimately he will be successful Steve
quickly
well it depends what you mean by success
I mean I think it is
um uh I I it's all the things Sarah says
it's but it's also clearly or I've never
met the guy but he is evidently
genuinely shocked by the treatment of
some media Outlets towards him towards
his mother towards other people I know
politicians who are shocked but they're
too scared to do anything because the
parts of the media in this country are
incredibly powerful and intimidating
knowing all of that he has decided to
take them off now as I say it's
multi-layered but one of the motors is
that and I think the newspapers will
have to or you know whoever his targets
are will have to accept that part of it
is that and he is sincere about it now
whether he wins this or not who knows
but I think it is a sort of impressive
thing to do given that he could just
have an easy wealthy affluent life
wherever he chooses to be instead he's
got a project and it is the same
extraordinary okay we're gonna we're
gonna talk about it in a lot more detail
in the 11 o'clock hour so we'll park
that for now and and let's get some more
papers out the way as well starting with
the front page of the telegraph
interesting enough they don't really
talk too much about Prince Harry they've
got a picture of the Princess of Wales
instead on their front page read into
that as you will and they lead heavily
on the visit with uh Brushy sonak in the
United States as we've been leading here
on Skies as well apparently the headline
reads that he's going to tell Biden the
UK can lead on AI it's going to Britain
will take the lead on tackling the
threat posed by artificial intelligence
which is so that's going to tell Joe
Biden um tomorrow how do you think this
is going to go for him Sarah
um well I I don't know because you never
know with Joe Biden whether he's sort of
alive or not or listening but the fact
is that I mean sunak is right to try and
take the lead on it he wants to have a
he wants to have a an organization a bit
like the atomic energy organization
that's basically in charge of making
sure that AI doesn't get out of control
or that it isn't that it isn't so
unregulated that we I mean one of the
big issues over the last 10 15 years has
been the internet and and it's and it's
sort of the way it's taken over its life
our lives but it's completely
unregulated and I think the idea is not
to make the same mistake with AI which
could have much more far-reaching
consequences
um there's a lot of scaremongering at
the moment about AI you know the debate
a lot of people think it can do a lot of
good A lot of people are terrified that
it's going to we're all going to turn
into you know uh the Terminator so I
think the most important thing is to try
and have some sort of Regulation and I
think uh for Rishi soon that's in lead
the way on this is quite a good idea I
know that the cabinet are quite divided
over this because half of them think
that AI is great because it can make
everything more efficient in government
and then the other half are a bit
worried about the Terminator aspect of
it so I think it's something that needs
to be discussed and it needs to be
openly discussed and it you know there
needs to be a proper convention about it
we can't just bury our heads in the sand
and we've had Elon Musk and various
other people saying the whole project
needs to be paused until we've got a
handle on it so I think his it's good
that he's responding yeah um Steve Sarah
mentioned scare mongering that the
telegraph themselves says it comes just
days after one Mr sennak's top advisors
warned that AI could kill humans I wipe
out Humanity within two years unless
action was taken now I mean where do you
stand on this debate
well well that scared the life out of me
I you know I read that briefly and it's
terrifying but
um what happens at these meetings and I
by the way you know I fully sympathize
with sooner he'll be exhausted it's
draining as well as exciting to be you
know in Washington in the white house
but quite often not much comes out of
them and this is just a briefly of
number 10 saying well we'd like to take
the lead and soon we'll discuss this
with Biden no doubt others will try and
take the lead on this um there will have
to be a coordinated effort at some point
but um the headline implies a kind of
sweeping Grandeur as soon as comes into
Washington say we're going to take the
lead but actually it shows that there
isn't a huge amount that's going to come
out of this meeting between the two of
them
um an aspiration for Brit to take the
lead fine
um but you know a few years ago there
was a talk of a trade deal with America
uh it's about 25
000 miles metaphorically from that
okay we'll leave it there Steve and
Sarah thank you so much plenty more from
those two uh in terms of the papers in
just a few minutes time
now uh The Fallout from the dam breach
in Ukraine is continuing as you know
this evening we're going to discuss that
and plenty more what's in the papers
after this short breakage
foreign
[Music]
I smile Sometimes I Cry Sometimes I'm
I'm very happy that I was able to have
such a a long career with these songs
well you said I think you were the most
successful black pop group ever yes
that's what we were told after 22
billion hits on Tick Tock and
and every World everywhere in the world
people listen to our Songs amazing uh
what's your connection with Windrush my
father and my mother came to the UK in
the early 50s and I joined them later on
so my connection to Windrush is that I
am one of the wind Rush babies put it
that way
um some of them were left in the
Caribbean and never ever saw their
parents again fortunately for me and my
brothers we were able to join our
parents after a separation I think that
um
had this problem not happen that when
Rush became wind Rush meaning people
were sent home and or sent back to the
Caribbean we wouldn't even be having
this conversation today and I'm very
grateful that we have this privilege to
talk about what it was like of course
when I came here
um as a as a young child
um intimidated by everything having to
get to know everyone even my my parents
my siblings that's my story but there
are many other people of the Windrush
generation who would have gone through
similar experiences either joining their
parents as I said or not being able to
join their parents growing up in school
we had to get to know the system had to
get to know to be to be received by the
system the teachers to like us or not to
like us to Value us or not to buy value
US it was quite difficult I think for a
lot of us to assimilate to get into a
culture that we did not really know
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello there very good evening and
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me tonight is Steve
Richards and Sarah Vine welcome to you
both thank you so much for bearing with
us tonight
um and we're going to have a look at the
rest of the top stories in the front
pages of uh tomorrow's papers let's kick
off with the guardian now uh Pippa Korea
political editor of that paper another
scoop for her of course she is a regular
on the Press preview here on Sky News
and Sarah let's come to you for this
um what do you make of what Pippa has
alleged here saying that Boris and
Carrie Johnson hosted a close friend who
helped plan their wedding overnight at
Checkers when a number of Kobe
restrictions were in place she says A
lady called Dixie Maloney a corporate
events organizer stayed at Checkers when
there was effectively a ban on people
who weren't part of households staying
overnight what'd you make of this
well they say that she was working for
them and therefore it was allowed under
the rules I think it just shows how
crazy those rules and regulations were
because I think if you had a reasonable
but he met them didn't he
exactly so that they claim uh that that
she was there under that she was trying
to be there that they checked all the
rules and it was okay for her to be
there
um I think the thing is it's a bit of a
gray area what the relationship with
this girl called Dixie why they all got
such strange names anyway Dixie
um uh uh what their relationship was
whether it was just purely work or
whether there was a crossover into
friends you know often in politics uh
that happens uh people work together and
then they become friends so I suppose if
you're in a situation where
um you've got some strange rules about
lockdown uh which are a little bit
indecipherable it's easy to to shade
into the gray but yes I mean this is
just I mean this is better this is this
is an extension you could scoop when she
worked at the mirror
um it's more to do with uh it's more to
do with the sort of covered lockdown uh
partygate Scandal
um and it will just keep running and
running I think as more and more little
tidbits like this come out
okay we're gonna move on because we're
tight on time tonight and we want to
have a look at how the Metro is covering
what's been an extraordinary story for
us here blowing up of this Dam in
Ukraine uh Steve the Metro saying floody
Maniac having blown up down Putin's next
move could be to Target a nuclear plant
what do you make of its coverage
uh well it's deeply depressing and a
sign that this is going to go on and on
I've been uh at this press preview where
newspapers at times have carried reports
which suggested that um uh Russia was in
Retreat perhaps faithfully and then you
get something like this uh which is you
know uh appalling on so many different
levels but it's not a sign of retreat
and
um you know the question is posed every
now and again and needs to be how is
this going to end how do Wars end
um and it's not at all clear and as you
say the suggestion as well as reporting
the consequences of the flooding of the
dam in effect
um the speculation of targeting nuclear
plants I mean it's it looks as if things
are gonna intensify
um and um it's not at all clear how this
is all going to end
and quick look at the Ft before we do
this in a bit more detail on the top of
the hour uh the Ft we've got the U.S
Edition rather than the UK Edition but a
fantastic picture of of New York City
and the skyline people we think are
probably doing some yoga or some sort
and of course the smoke high alert smog
stifles New York we've had some
extraordinary pictures ourselves from
Mark Stone I mean talk about pollution
you wouldn't want to be there at the
moment Sarah would you
now this is the smoke from the wildfires
isn't it further north in Canada no it
looks awful it reminds me of those
pictures you should see of London in the
1950s
um when it was known as The Big Smoke
yeah I mean I'm very unpleasant
um apparently it's affecting Washington
as well so I hope Rishi soon that's got
his mask
oh yes Steve a quick word I mean it it
would be terrible to be there right now
and you can just imagine the health
effects can't I mean it's certainly one
shot that we had the sky was orange
never seen anything quite like it
yeah I mean amazing television pictures
aren't they because you know you can
convey right away how weird it is yeah
one breath and you think that's the
equivalent of knocking about 20 which
Gore Watts or something you know it is
okay uh yeah we'll leave it there Steve
Richards and Sarah Vine thank you so
much for that and we'll see you very
quickly at the top of the hour for now
though let's have a quick look at the
weather for you
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well tomorrow looks much like the recent
days but the Spanish name storm Oscar is
going to bring warm humid air and some
heavy thundery showers into the South to
end the week another rather cloudy start
tomorrow but Island Northern Ireland and
the far south and west of Britain will
see some good Sunny spells temperatures
will be like this morning's Bush and
we'll see early Cloud largely burning
off by midday linger in parts of the
north and east especially over the coast
they'll be chilly there warm elsewhere
and increasingly humid in the windy
South Coastal Gales are possible in the
southwest the afternoon bringing little
change
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
[Music]
foreign